I love talking about celebrity culture
if there's a newt like Sean Sean Penn
and El Chapo I could talk about that for
[ __ ] four hours what do you think of
that Sean is a friend of mine and I like
him but I mean you really like him are
you just saying no no I like him he's
very funny he also takes himself very
seriously and I didn't know he was a
journalist right I mean what the [ __ ] is
that but look you're becoming a
journalist I'm not a journalist weed I'm
a writer I've always written but I'm not
I don't qualify myself as a journalist
and nor would anyone else so you were
shocked when you saw that Sean Penn was
now interviewing El Chapo I just didn't
understand why he was there like if you
were going to get some blow okay I get
that part but you were really going like
what is the war on drugs like why would
it be necessary I thought immediately
they must be covering up something else
like he el chapo was caught and so sean
is just like oh [ __ ] I just met with him
if they catch me I got to make up a
story for why I was there I better write
an article really quick right like that
that would be brilliant
that was my instant